what's next let's talk about this
bitcoin seizure that happened all right
listen if you're not into cryptocurrency
or finance keep listening because you're
going to like this it's true because
this is another this is very funny well
let's see yeah we'll talk about the
seizure but we care more about you know
yeah yeah okay so like i'll give you a
little run down so like in 2016
uh some like 20 000
bitcoin was it 20 000. i wanted maybe
180 000 90 000 something 90 000 bitcoin
or 120 000 something like that uh was
stolen from
bit of finnex
which is one of the largest exchanges at
the time
so at this time in 2016 that was worth
70 million
and then fast forward whatever it's been
five years and it's
that amount of bitcoin is worth 3.6
billion dollars yeah so the people that
stole it were this couple
and they tried to launder launder it i
guess through like a series of crypto
transactions and
uh the feds ended up tracing them
they found the wallet with most of the
bitcoin in he had sold 700 million
dollars worth of bitcoin damn and they
found the rest of it and they seized it
it's like the biggest financial seizure
of all time wow and now they're
like you know about to uh
get prosecuted basically
but the funny thing is is that the
he he was a yc founder i think he
started some company and they and he
went through yc and she
is like a
self-proclaimed like comedy rapper yeah
and let's put that in quotes what their
[ __ ] don't put that in quotes no we're
comedy rappers she's a comedy rapper
yeah yeah so this is her right here
a picture of her with the hat that says
zero [ __ ]
what's her name heather morgan
or razzle what is it razzle con
razzle con is her rap name and honestly
she's she can spit
are we allowed to play some of it yeah
let's play something oh man this poor
girl is going to get all these hits but
she can't even enjoy it from jail i know
you can still enjoy it from jail that's
true
you hear you hear through the grapevine
she's finally popping off i mean plenty
plenty of rappers do numbers while in
jail it's true that's
that's not the issue it's just that
um we'll never get a follow-up album
wait real fast while we're looking at
this
um i had just seen the other day before
this news came out that someone was
watching the wallets and was watching
like hey 90 000 bitcoin just moved from
wallet to wallet and it's related to the
hack
and then
wouldn't you know it it comes out and
now there's speculation that that was
actually the united states government oh
moving in wow which is wild like can you
imagine being the guy who's got to like
well i hope i punched everything in
right and this 90 000 bitcoin just yeah
seriously it goes without a hitch yeah
but it's also crazy that sorry that that
that like there's a wallet sitting there
with ninety thousand bitcoin and
everyone can see and everyone's like
this is the guy who stole it yeah but no
one knows
who he is i think eventually they like
transfer like they tried to launder it
and eventually it ended up in a in an
account like coinbase or something where
you have to like verify your identity so
like their names were attached to it
but that's the thing that's kind of
interesting about crypto is that
you think it's anonymous but in order to
actually like
get it out to usd
you have to attach some sort of identity
to it yeah yeah for this exact reason
defeats the whole okay
all right let's just razzle con in
vietnam menace to society oh i've never
seen this one
neither have i i saw the like really
popular
yo yeah
uh
oh jesus yeah oh god
okay from from what a waste
you can't get as high as me synesthesia
i can see big
wow what are you doing
that was just getting good
ben's freaking out
i like i'm enjoying the [ __ ] is this at
first i'm like this sucks ass but then
i'm like this woman had 3.6 billion
dollars
that's kind of tight that a total idiot
had that much money right she gets to
just purely live out her dream she
doesn't have to worry about money yeah
she doesn't have to worry about uh
quality
to do it yeah this is what a total
dum-dum does with six billion yeah or
3.6 billion it is pretty endearing that
um yeah the the person behind the
[ __ ] money is a [ __ ] total [ __ ]
did they did they actually do the hack
or did they just no one knows yet that's
so insane they won't yeah i don't think
they'll know until they go to court but
um it would be sick if she had a line in
there about having billions of dollars
could you imagine that yeah people like
come on no you don't
but it was real
i have three billion dollars
i acted from bitter phoenix
i i could swear that i saw a tick tock
where she's doing it might have been
photoshopped because it was just a still
but it was like one of those ones where
it's you know
choose between this and this and it's
like
uh a [ __ ] apartment i don't know or
a hack
a hack some some amount of bitcoin it
must have been fake now that i'm saying
yeah i wish we had the foresight to pull
it up but she does some like
some
advice videos about like how to do be
good at business and stuff and
i really wish we could find the stick
doc she basically is like
you need to replicate
delegate
and [ __ ] i don't steal three billion
dollars
and she's just it's it's [ __ ]
nonsense we gotta find this please look
at her
i mean razzalisms
she her face is
she's she's truly god she's a [ __ ]
dense yeah she's so dorky too which is
the th you wouldn't think that someone
who stole that much money would be so
dorky
just don't just
go to she's so go to the beach twee and
what are you doing this for
yeah giving business tips on you don't
have to do that and then she's like
there are videos of her just like eating
big pancakes like and it's just so
cute she's like these are supposed to be
the best like and her husband there it
is yeah yeah she's eating a big pancake
and that's a big old and there's her
husband the guy that's the guy yep
and she like calls him
look at him he's probably like [ __ ]
keep a low profile goddamn yeah this is
why regular people can't become
billionaires they don't know what to do
with it yeah right you're skipping too
many steps
where you learn hey i'll tell you what
vlad
this man comes in he's got security
two of the scariest guys you ever seen
that's how you know there's not enough
security in these videos yeah there's
none should be bouncers like standing in
the background
they should be renting out all these
places that they eat at they should be
really establishing their wealth yeah
not going to um papas and beer and
asking the cashier can you film this for
my music video yeah then shooting off a
super soaker yeah
too regular i would kidnap her
what the [ __ ]
i mean for the
wasn't the course for the bitcoin
no one was no one asked that no one
uh and back to noelle's question yeah i
guess i would uh yeah personally i think
i would probably
cause we were talking earlier for the
viewers slash listener we i
see this is where the brain doesn't make
the connection is that we were talking
about it before recording no we were not
i was about kidnapping we weren't
talking about committing the act of
kidnapping but i i read a headline about
crypto people getting kidnapped for
ransom oh yes yes in my brain i made the
connection i would kidnap her that's all
that came out so right i would kidnap
her so what was that like what was that
article that you yeah where
behind the paywall it is oh [ __ ] that
dude
yeah
that's i hate that yeah pay walls pay
walls who would pay for content if
you've never smoked weed add literal
woodstock
you're not a stoner
[Music]
i would i know i would
jesus
that's it pisses me off why not you know
what here's a free business idea for you
okay give it to us is this a razzle no
no this is this isn't a razzle that [ __ ]
that
this is a basil okay because the beak
has been because my name is okay because
the b is the man because my name i like
that
thank you
no because more often than not in
benzene when you
come here go ahead embezzlement what are
you gonna say oh god
it seems like you gained a little weight
okay clearly you guys can hear that
because you're laughing
it does look like it though right yeah
yeah you look great you look great man
stop it
dude you look totally fine thank you
thank you
anyway so when you're on twitter and you
come across an article on business
insider or new york times or whatever
and it's like you reached your limit
would you like to subscribe you just say
okay [ __ ] this i'm out right yeah what
if it were to give you the option to buy
it a la carte you just hey would you
like to buy this one article for one
dollar yes i would i would you've been
pushing this forever i won one dollar
one dollar that's not a buck you know
you can subscribe for like three
uh that's too much
but you're gonna read more than three
articles in the month no i'm not
i just want the one
give me the choice
do you want the rice and beans or do you
want it a la carte i want it all a cart
it's a good idea but it have to it would
have to be like ten cents right it'd
have to be much okay okay 10 cents
whatever you want what if you name your
price guys journalism is dying and this
is what we're coming up with no let them
die but i'm offering you water in the
desert
and
that's simply how it feels
yep
i would agree that's exactly how it
feels
oh [ __ ]
you